salut à tous envergure de retour un
podcast est un sujet un homme au tchaï à
bagis il est en dernière année à kansas
il explose pour ce début d'année on peut
le dire il est donc un candidat sérieux
pour être en quelque sorte le christ
duarte et de la draf 2022 c'est à dire
un senior qui va être drafté homéo ça
veut dire quoi premier tour top 20
encore mieux on va voir ça avec les
totally spies
allan hughes et nico bonjour bonsoir
comment allez-vous
glauque je suis globules
clover clo clo clo vers la blonde
effectivement j'avais vous demander
votre totally spies préférait avant d'y
aller donc alan c'est plutôt clover
nikos et ses 70 génération ou justin sur
sa fameuse nation mais qui ressemble à
zion parce que sinon nous allions c'est
moi
non c'est plus des jeunes filles assez
figée au coeur ouais juste gérer
exactement bon allez génériques
[Musique]
à leurs hôtes chaillac belgique campsas
géo que c'est évidemment sa fiche
disponible sur le site envergure point
ces eaux c'est d'ailleurs si vous tapez
juste son nom dans le moteur de
recherche le plus utilisé
normalement vous tomber dessus assez
vite donc sur sa fiche points forts
points faibles stats mensurations c'est
donc un poste 2-3 il aura 22 ans l'année
prochaine mais c'est aussi un homme qui
a une histoire on commence par son
histoire et c'est lui qui s'en occupe
une c'est à toi qui l'as pas écoute
comme tu l'as dit poche aiac badji donc
dernières années à kansas alors lui il a
grandi kansas city dans le missouri donc
juste à côté il a fait son lycée là bas
c'était un prospect pas du tout
référence et les deux trois étoiles donc
pas du tout convoitait rentrer dans les
seniors d'ailleurs il commence le basket
à cet art ce jeune homme puisque lui
préfèrent le foot par le soccer comme
ils disent là-bas n'ont pas pas le pouce
et puis enfin deux lycées l'explosion
peu comme cette année l'exposent à
kansas il est recruté par kansas il y va
première année il doit ils doivent être
normalement et puis finalement il ya une
grosse blessure de monsieur udoka du
blick été drafté au premier tour et donc
il finit par jouer un petit peu c'est
une révélation 2éme année joue un peu
plus troisième année il est titulaire
vraiment installé deuxième troisième
option à cette année c'est le leader
offensif que défensif des patrons de
l'équipe c'est ça une équipe où on
trouve une équipe qui lui fait partie
des dix des dix meilleurs du pays on
peut le dire sans trop s'avancer
totalement ils sont classés dans le top
10 ils ont une défaite pour le moment et
ils sont bien partis avec des vrais
joueurs référence dans la victoire 9 du
coup tu y es tu ne vas aimer d'or est ce
que tu sais si au shag belgique
dès son père le pousser vers le soccer
est ce que son père est un sportif est
ce qu il a des sportives dans sa famille
ouais bah le papa du coup elle lui a
fait pas mal de foot il y a joué à
l'université
est en fait ils s'arrêtaient parce qu'il
a eu il a vu qu'il avait du potentiel en
deuxième année du coup de lycée donc
voilà après j'ai pas d'autres frères ou
soeurs maman qui aurait fait à notre
sport plus développés mais il ya
toujours un événement était la maman et
une bourse aussi pour faire du sport à
l'université mais je ne sais pas quel
sport
alors faire jouer van gaal a
ok voilà la famille se complète petit à
petit sachant que
je crois que la stat ckoi 7 % de tous
les toutes les personnes qui vont à
l'université parviennent à avoir une
bourse pour le sport donc ça veut dire
que quand tu es dans les 7 %
généralement t2
tu fais partie d'une certaine élite
athlétique donc ça confirme que au chac
jihad et gêne plus tôt plutôt favorable
après donc en parlant de gênes justement
après l'histoire de shay on va parler de
son corps c'est quelque chose qui est
indispensable pour ceux qui ne sont
jamais écoutés canton ce chaos d'un
joueur quand on essaie de voir s'il va
être bon plus tard il est hyper
important de scruter le corps des
prospects voir ceux qui ne se commet ici
ils se déplacent sur le terrain quels
sont ses points forts ses points faibles
physiquement et donc ça c'est le travail
de nico aujourd'hui
et bien au style il fait 6 five donc un
mètre 96
98 kg je trouve d'ailleurs qu'il ait
fait pas mystère que quand tu le
regardes visuellement il n'a pas le
corps il ressemble pas quelqu'un qui est
proche des 100 kg il fait 2 m 01
d'envergure donc c'est plus 5
c c'est un athlète c'est fin c'est
musclé dessinée il n'y a pas un pet de
grèce
j'ai l'impression montre qu'à ce qui me
saute aux yeux et c'était surtout le cas
l'an dernier c'est que c'est une sorte
de des jeunes tu aimerais mais qui a pas
sauter de repas quoi qui avec à manger
normalement à la cantine il a il a des
épaules
d'ailleurs ça lui permet de finir au
cercle mais ça on y reviendra il est
aérien sans être vraiment verticale
le la détente en termes de hauteur bien
sûr ils donnent facilement on n'en est
pas là mais mais je n'ai pas aérien
comme comme peuvent l'être des des
superbes athlètes où les flics
ce qui me saute aux yeux en terme de
déplacement c'est sa capacité à faire ce
qu'on appelle est-ouest nord-sud c'est à
dire qu'il a vraiment une capacité h à
tourner les hanches a changé de
direction très rapidement alors certains
aiment bien les gens du oui c'est les
appuis du footballeur bon moi j'ai joué
au foot une quinzaine d'années je les ai
passées à plein donc c'est quelqu'un qui
en terme de deux corps pour un ailier a
un corps parfait c'est possible mais mes
copains ont des trucs à eybens huguenots
signal en message que la le wing spa
n'est pas le même l'envergure
effectivement moi aussi j'ai sur les
chiffres du draft combine puisqu'il l'a
l'année dernière il a il a testé les
eaux comme disent les américains ou
draft combined avant de retirer son nom
de la draft est donc là il s'est fait
mesuré est officiellement ces six thèmes
dont 6 100 cède 2,08 well environ mais
j'écris tellement mal
j'ai cru que j'allais me 6 x en fait
j'ai mis 6 ait donc c'est ça merci les
gars et donc ouais c'est vrai que sur
sur tout ce qui est les épreuves de
force et agilité il était plus tôt il
était plutôt bien placé il était aussi
le 3 ou 4e avec le plus faible taux de
masse graisseuse
présent à ce nba combat ce qui veut dire
à la fois qu'ils se préparent bien et
comme tu disais nico qu'il est assez
naturellement sec quoique y a que du
muscle en fait
donc donc effectivement way sur les lane
agility il était dans les premiers dans
l'est dans les environs toujours à peu
près dans les mêmes eaux que if pons
d'ailleurs à part pour le vertical l'ip
évidemment pour la détente ou même s'il
n'est pas si loin même si il est pas si
loin en détente sèche un peu à dix
centimètres de moi mais par contre en
détente maximale il a que trois
centimètres de moins qui font ce
qu'elles mènent contre 13
c'est là où je pense qu'ils en tout cas
moi je mets un une sorte de ola sur le
sur la combined parce que en situation
de match
que ça soit sur contre attaques ça se
passe il arrive sur dur au monde off
honnêtement il n'a pas la tête au cercle
oui oui je vois ce que tu dois y est
d'accord il est il et c'est un acte oui
d'accord il a il à la détente pour les
tests mais il n'a pas forcément une
détente fonctionnel
en match on a eu le corps on a eu
l'histoire on veut la carte de visite en
tout cas le
l'atout majeur pour ocha gbadji pour la
draft 2022 quel est ton son son attrait
point j'aime nba c'est à toi de nous en
parler à l'année
sa propre cote et sa propreté offensive
et son
sens au plancher c'est à dire je sais ce
que auch agouazi va faire sur un terrain
professionnel d'ailleurs j'ai pas lui en
demander énormément plus que d'être un
finisseur d'action
un genre qui bouge sans ballon est un
genre qui ont mis des tyrans spots up
pas ce que c'est
il ne fait déjà très bien à kansas même
s'il a un rôle un peu plus important
mais c'est pas un joueur qui devra
vraiment pour moi changer son rôle quand
il est arrivé en nba et a jamais fait
plus de 11 % de passes décisives compter
sur des quantités sur le terrain il n'a
jamais eu à un dribble suffisamment
trouve solides pour porter la balle et
est assez bon dans cette dent dans la
crasse au bon moment il va pas beaucoup
sur la ligne par contre ce qui fait très
bien ça bouge sans ballon et propose des
solutions de transition et il avait dû
ressentir d'année en année la
progression linéaire sur le tir elle est
très bonne et cette année il y a il y à
44% à 3 points sur un échantillon de 45
tentatives en sur trois quarts de ces
tirs qui sont du spot donc pour moi
c'est sa carte d'entrée c'est un joueur
que je pense frappe pas eu énormément de
bêtises sur un terrain un joueur qui
serait propre et qui a je pense qu'à un
plancher pour tout de suite apporté dans
une rotation
très bien et bien voilà la carte la
carte d'entrée par par alan
effectivement on a vu qu'il avait un
corps déjà prêt on a vu qu'ils avaient
une histoire assez linéaire aussi comme
tu disais à l'anis et émis tard au
basket hugues nous disaient qu'ils
avaient ensuite progresser petit à petit
avec un petit lit pense dernières années
lycée puis le même visiblement cette
année en tout cas ce qui est en train
d'arriver sur ses premiers mois donc ça
c'était la première partie on fait un
peu la carte d'identité du prospect donc
de chaillac bagis vous avez à peu près
les bases maintenant on va essayer de
rentrer dans le détail de savoir si pour
essayer d'estimer
de visualiser où pourrait se trouver le
joueur dans plusieurs années et pour ça
je posais des questions parce que moi
j'ai pas vu j'ai pas vu autant de films
que vous mais j'ai un peut éplucher les
stats j'ai un peu plus chez les stats
alors stade avancé pour bages il faut le
dire c'est quand même hyper solide ce
que ce soit aux boks place minds donc
c'est à dire est-ce que son équipe est
meilleure avec lui que sans lui sur le
terrain offensivement c'est le troisième
meilleur de toute la n 6 est
sur une autre stat avancée qui s'appelle
porte pas gars tu sais un nom un peu
barbare mais bref il est deuxième c'est
une stat qui prend en compte un peu tout
donc c'est des stats à prendre toujours
avec un astérisque mais généralement qui
peuvent confirmer ce qu'on voit aussi à
l'oeil et donc je vais vous poser des
questions sur des points qui
m'interrogent notamment sont aux deux
lancers francs
puisqu'on m'a décrit dans première
partie un joueur finalement assez
athlétique alors certes pas la tête
cercle disait disait nico mais quand
même assez athlétique taux de lancers
francs 10 9% c'est assez faibles voire
très faibles qu'on regarde l'historique
des joueurs draftés et surtout ça n'a
jamais été plus haut dans sa carrière
c'est pas une anomalie sur sur le début
de saison il a toujours eu un taux de
lancers francs inférieur à un taux de
lancers francs provoquée par dons
inférieurs à 23 % c'est-à-dire que pour
quatre tirs tentés il tente un
lancer-franc 6 à 25 % est donc cette
année 19 est ce que ça vous pose souci
ce côté je ne vais pas beaucoup sur la
ligne ou non
c'est dans ces par rapport à son jeu il
il se sert pas beaucoup de son dribble
au final il prend pas énormément il le
fait bien sûr mais il met la base de son
jeu c'est le tire donc du coup c'est
pour moi c'est logique qu'ils prouvent
pas beaucoup de fautes après sur le pas
la tête au cercle huguier pas d'accord
avec moi et c'est bien il faut qu'il
faut que tu le dises en live moi je vis
tu as vu des matchs aussi on a droit
d'être en désaccord alors allons-y là
dessus ouais bien sûr c'est juste que
j'attendais mon tout à prouver mon petit
tour
ouais je suis en fait je suis pas
d'accord sur les situations de
démarquage à travers le contact il un
boeing time i montrent pas forcément le
plus haut maintenant les lignes de fond
j'ai pas de meilleur joueur n 6 et qui
fait un des leurs cages ligne de fond et
qui montrent aussi haut que lui il est
vraiment imprenable et toutes les
défenses et elles vont pas le chercher
un tellement il est il est fort sur ce
secteur là pour le faible taux de
lancers francs il ya plusieurs choses
comme ils le disent beaucoup de tirs
beaucoup de jeu sans ballon donc sur des
actions où il va être des marques est
parce qu il le fait très très bien donc
la défense elle est pas en place et
troisième chose c'est qu'il utilise
beaucoup la planche il utilise beaucoup
au niveau de la main droite il s'écarte
beaucoup de son défenseur pour prat star
bloqué beaucoup d'utilisation de la
planche et donc lironde pas vraiment
dans son défenseur direct et dans les
grosses poignées intéressant et bien pas
de grille mais
là sachant s'agit pas qu'ils perdent
accord mais il n'a pas un tribut l'élite
et le pied pour porter le ballon
n'empêche en train de bouillonner
donc on ne demandera pas de le faire et
donc ça sert à rien et alors souvent
alors parfois pas tout le temps souvent
les joueurs j'ai pas mal d'exemples et
les joueurs avaient un faible taux de
lancers francs tentés comme lui sont
soit des spécialistes du tir soit
quelques autres exceptions mais c'est
pas souvent des joueurs qui sont
va dire très positive défensivement pour
leur équipe
nico disait très fort sur les
déplacements latéraux
très solide u10 est au contact alors
est-ce que effectivement défensivement
tout ça se traduit par une belle
présence puisque je finis jusque là
dessus pour pour les stades défensive
il n'est pas les mêmes pour les stats
agrégé défensive ans et que c'est moins
important mais il l'est pas il est pas
très très bon et j'aurai une autre
question là dessus après mais est-ce que
défensivement il peut tenir sa place en
nba combien de position peut-il couvrir
alors à l'année mondiale à la discussion
chemin planète draft a pas très
longtemps et pour moi c'est si ce n'est
le meilleur des 20 un des meilleurs si
ce n'est le meilleur défenseur
actuellement une si elle y tient
actuellement la lie tient d et lille et
il tient des arrières ilisu sur les
pourtours de balle extérieurs les plus
les plus vifs les plus petits les plus
rapides et ça se passe bien parce qu'ils
ont très très bien grosses anticipations
et conteste les prises de position bost
bas et boxe est au rebond donc pour moi
on y voit une bille est une équipe qui
le prend à elle peut tout faire avec lui
défensivement sans problème en plus il a
une forte longueur de bras et il
comprend très bien le jeu la seule chose
c'est qui peut parfois se fait reprendre
sur des communes en titre sur anticipent
ils peuvent parfois se fait reprendre
sur des démarquages dont son tout ça ça
lui arrive assez régulièrement est sûre
on anticipe pour un switch quoi que ce
soit et le du coup son hamac en slip au
niveau du panier et il se fait prendre
le dessus
et alors comment expliquer qu'ils alors
quelqu'un d'autre vous les réponses
allez-y ouais je
j'adore être en désaccord sur les
pendant les émissions parce que ça
permet de d'amener du pour et du contre
c'est un excellent défenseur mais là où
moi je veux mettre un petit bémol c'est
que tu l'as tu l'as où tu en a parlé un
petit peu tu as dit qu'il est dans
l'anticipation et du coup il peut se
faire avoir moi j'ai trouvé que face à
des joueurs qui ressemble à des postes 3
nba c'était vraiment ans qui avec des
épaules
situe la tacc droit devant ses portes
ouvertes dans le sens où voilà après
j'ai regardé que cinq matchs mais et le
celui qui m'a marqué ses façades ilana
des rousses ou de saint john ou à chaque
fois que des mousses ou l'attaqué
épaules en tête soit il voulait pas
faire de faute soit il s'était fait
avoir parce que le premier appui l'été
il était déjà dépassée mais du coup il
s'est fait en fond c'est quoi donc après
c'est peut-être
effectivement sur les cinq matches et là
où il ya de moins bien défendu mais
je juste pour mettre un bémol à tous et
tous ces gros point positif
je le vois plus défendre très
efficacement sur des deux que sur
détroit
intéressant alors qu'il a le
théoriquement le physique pour défendre
sur du 3 ans puisqu'en 96 2 m de 8
d'envergure et 98 kg normalement il ya
pas de coller aux problèmes aussi je
peux rajouter fait que les deux et de
profilés convoi le mans ancien et qui
sont les plus difficiles à défendre en
nba ce sur lequel certains projettent
qui pourra bien défendre c'est à dire
les porteurs de ballon switch et les
ailiers les ailiers complètes sont donc
plus grand plus puissant plus rapide
pour moi j'ai du mal à ça avec ça parce
que je n'ai pas vu en fait oui oui il
était en facilement les porteurs de bons
les dossiers mais le porteur de balle et
nice est allé porter de balayer match
contre ce sera super d2 françois en
équipe
pas négatif qui fera s'il en est alors
des stats
of the stone les stocks se sont pas
excellentes mais en fait ils sont même
très faible en dessous chéri ouais c'est
pas c'est peut-être le schéma de bill
celle qui veut pas trop le faire jouer
l'interception et tout ça mais défenseur
de l'équipe vraiment très très bon tu
vois là
il y à 90 matchs
n'diaye 84 étudiants elle aura plus de
100 matches avec la période de la draft
dans une grosse conférence sur les îles
il aura vu il aura vu des choses je
serais assez jeu peut-être aller refaire
j'aimerais bien les revoir ce qu'il a
fait l'an dernier contre eux quelques
nigam s'il a défendu j'ai plus trop de
souvenirs mais oui parce que c'est pas
voilà ça c'est un profil nba pour moi
cette année il en a joué les héros ont
très nettement
donc tes joueurs qui pourront avoir la
baule en béquilles après un contre un je
n'ai pas trop vu cette année donc c'est
juste la petite limite sur sa mélancolie
de défense collective il est super super
fort non c'est plutôt rassurant puisque
alors vous avez coupé ma prochaine
question et c'est tant mieux j'avais
posé une question sur le pelé making
défensif qui est vraiment faible en
termes de style et blocks en plein
meeting c'est ça c'est fait des jeux des
choses se passent défensivement des
événements provoqués des événements
défensif sur lequel l'ailé les très bons
défenseurs excellent d'habitude on
pensait en nba à des matis style
des vendeurs bilan voilà ce genre de
profil et quand j'ai fait une recherche
par rapport aux personnes qui ont été
drafté depuis pas 10 15 ans
avec donc - huile à moins de 2% de style
et blocks je veux pas rentrer dans le
détail sur ce que ça veut dire mais en
gros les gens les personnes qui ont été
drafté qu'aujourd'hui un rôle en nba
généralement avec ses stats là sont des
spécialistes du tir à trois points quand
je dis spécialistes c'est vraiment des
gens qui arty
certains avec succès d'autres moins et
donc du mc dermott
alex burke ce qui a depuis on peut
changer son jeu etc mais voilà
et il ya quelques exceptions peut-être
que c'est ici qu'on peut trouver des
comparaisons puisque c'est là où je vais
vous amené des comparaisons donc les
exceptions la semi ojjeh leye georgienne
ayo dosunmu est un peu plus bas dans les
comparaisons c'est à dire avec plus de
plaies making donc plus de passes
décisives mais aussi un peu plus de
balles perdues on a ça dit baye qui est
aussi un peu plus grand
lequel de laquelle de quel de ses nom et
où est-ce que vous avez d'autres noms
qui vous semblent correspondre à un rôle
et à un type de joueur que ce que ocha
et badji peut devenir
si c'est shannon bool faire le saint
jean b spécialiste du tir à trois points
de la saison qui concède gilbert qui
prend des couleurs pas mes distances
cette année mais ça ne paye si c'est ça
c'est bien parce que sa digue baissé
c'est ce qu'on veut à côté de l'un
porteur de balle un genre qui défend
coupe et surtout mais à trois points 4 9
août moi je vais pas mentir je suis
peut-être un peu moins haut sur sur
magic cube par exemple qui pensent que
peut y avoir peut-être un développement
balle en main sur la création secondaire
moi je veux jouer en lui un super soldat
qui mettra des trois qui coupera et qui
voit la fra fra des actions défensives
je vois je pense pas que le potentiel
est si haut que ça mais aussi voilà
c'est un rire un late bloomer ans et
school et que une production qui
s'améliore d'année en année je pense que
si ces sadiques but et c'est très bien
on fait déjà mais du coup c'est qui ce
super soldat aujourd'hui moyens de vivre
à dorian finesse miss lorraine devenu
chaud et c'est très bien
jeu de la comparaison avec tony stèle
dont le
dans le rôle qui pourrait avoir dû
vraiment du soulier andy qui arrivent et
quand même assez physique assez
développé lui pour le coi pas confirmé
derrière dans le bling-bling mais en
plongeant qui va voir ça ok intéressant
maintenant pour arriver à ce parce qu'il
ya toujours une marche aujourd'hui il
n'est pas des joueurs qu'on a cité c'est
sûr même si il est il à un plancher déjà
assez haut et même s'il peut être un
crazy heart et on parlera de ses
premières années potentiel en nba plus
tard avant pour atteindre le potentiel
dont on parle
il faut avoir une certaine certaine
psychologie
premièrement et deuxièmement j'aimerais
qu'on reparle du tir ensuite mais
d'abord psychologiquement est ce que
vous aimez ce que vous voyez ce sur le
langage corporel les interviews les
retours qui a pu avoir dans la presse
j'aime j'aime le fait qu'il est qu'il
est très calme qu'il est maître de ses
émotions et et il a c'est un petit peu
le
lui qui va les calmer rémy martin rémy
martin qui est peu qui est plus rare est
longue plus volcanique aurait mis
rémy qui est insupportable à regarder
jouer ainsi on aime le basket mais mais
en tout cas akbar jia ce côté voilà
comme d'un on donc là dessus en
interview
d'après un
ami qui travaille chez espn c'est un mec
super intelligent et est calme et
réfléchi donc il n'y a que des des
drapeaux verts là dessus ça c'est bien
alan est ce que tu as des choses à dire
sur le côté psy moi j'avais peur que ça
soit l'équipe de rémy martin qui était
qui est pour moi l'un des joueurs les
plus kaki et terre depuis 2 3ans saison
les gens les plus surcoté initiés
arizona state alors oui faisait des
stats et tout mais cette équipe allait
nulle part et il était un peu con mis en
avant comme le gros la grosse recrue
transfert de mule de kansas en fait je
trouve ça qu'il faut que ça se fasse
naturellement pourrait match de l'année
mais s'ils conjuguent en cédant au
garden à baïji fait un excellent match
on comprend de suite que c'est son
équipe et qu'il n'y a pas besoin d'en
faire des caisses pour que pour être un
peu de leaders comme l'a dit luc ça fait
quatre ans qu'il est là
il a connu plusieurs types d'équipés
puis il arrive dans la quatrième année
voilà c'est à lui de montrer dans un
effectif il n'y a pas non plus eu de
super star one donne autre chose comme
ça donc ça s'est fait de manière un peu
normal qu'ils prennent le lead mais en
même temps c'est normal parce que c'est
le c'est tout simplement le meilleur
joueur de tous mais un jour du pays je
pense hugues way juste après je prends
une remorque de nico qui nous dit qu'il
a démarré le basket à saison donc voilà
qu'on parle de l'est de blossom c'était
ça qui t'aiment retrait tard mais j'ai
un truc là dessus sur le sur la
mentalité faut rappeler que c'est un
joueur qui a subi deux saisons un peu
tronquée il ya deux ans saison kevin
march madness et l'an dernier il faut
annuler leur retour notre conférence
parce qu'ils ont un problème de bango de
coded est lui ça a beaucoup joué il
disait qu'il avait eu des propositions
au niveau de la draft mais le fait de
vraiment terminer un truc de boucler un
truc et le diester grand moment à cannes
ça lui plaisait et la deuxième chose
c'est que les joueurs y prennent souvent
des pauses pendant pendant la période
d'été etc lui travaille beaucoup
beaucoup et ils travaillent sur des
tenants des domaines un peu différent il
est revenue par exemple lui a demandé de
travailler son haendel et son jeu de
pieds dans ses fondamentaux de départ
bon ben voilà il a fait du soccer avec
l'équipe de kansas pour vraiment
s'entraîner là dessus il ya deux ans le
mode de travail et son tir en bas il
passe on était à bosser chanson tire
donc c'est un énorme bosseur
merci pour la transition sur le tir on
parlait de son futur rôle en nba vu ce
que vous m'avez dit vu les rebellés les
remarques sur le fait que ce soit un bon
défenseur d'equipe mais pas non plus le
l'immense bollène leur stoppeur ou en
tout cas pas certainement pas avec
certitude plus tôt et sur le fait qu' il
n'est pas encore le dribble pour faire
beaucoup d'autres choses que finir en
attaque
il me paraît évident que sans un tir
très très bon des cdd ses débuts en nba
il n'aura il n'aura pas de rôle est ce
que
le voyez avoir une diversité de tir
puisque c'est sale et très bon shooteur
c'est pas juste je suis bien à trois
points dans le corner
c'est ça la question entre le roleplay
on comptait un
des trois ou quatre
joueur d'une équipe qui
heureusement ambition c'est la marche la
plus délicate
pourquoi je disais l'an dernier que
quelques nigam était pour moi un
meilleur shooteur plus correct qui se
portent d'autres c'était dans la
diversité des tirs parce que c'est
beaucoup plus dur de prendre des tirs en
sortie de dribble je pense à j'ai une
très très faible expérience de
basketteur mais que de prendre des
quatre jeunes tout d'ailleurs tous les
quatre jeunes choses ne se valent pas
sortir d'un écran pour un style c'est
pas la même chose que se caler dans un
coin à 45° recevoir la passe sans
transition par un sas et c'est à noter
je trouve qu'il ya une meilleure
diversité de tir qu'avant dans les 4
chaînes shoot il peut en faire plusieurs
il ya le viaduc ou des flashs de pula
pas mes distances aussi qu'ils sont
assez intéressants même si les stats
amis aux amis des arts sont pas
exceptionnelles parce que j'ai trouvé 35
% par mois cette année à mes distances
on sur 31 ce qui est pas exceptionnel
donc ça c'est un axe de travail même
temps il prendra pas de milices ans a
oublié je pense donc
c'est une très bonne question et je
pense que c'est avec le travail car hier
69% 1c france mais il a bien beaucoup
progressé en détiendrait travail
mécanique entre la deuxième et la
troisième année avec un jeu beaucoup
plus fluide beaucoup moins cassé au
niveau du coude aussi donc voilà gros
travail mécanique là dessus à l'anil le
deal de l'évolution dans la prise de
tien cela n'aura ni envoyé presque que
du catch and shoot cette année on a
quatre chaînes shoot enfin fin de chaîne
on as catch and shoot en transition il
les prend on attire sous pression et
comme il a en difficulté main gauche on
a beaucoup il ya un pic qui vient pour
lui je dribble un rythme un gaucher
ensuite je prends un poulpe à trois
points ce qu'on voyait pas du tout avant
nico sur la part non sur la variation
sur la variété tirs ou tués à une autre
question
j'ai une autre question mais fais les
choses à dire sur la variété de tir pour
compléter tu parlais de skis et ski sera
pas capable de prendre tout type de tir
comme le disait il à demeurer le basket
en 2016 ça veut dire que ça fait cinq
ans qu'ils jouent au basket
on a vu là la manière dont il a pu
progresser
sur l'eau sur son tir aujourd'hui après
écran tir après l'écran il est vraiment
efficace comme l'a dit lui en transition
par contre après dribbles il peut y
avoir des sacrées écart donc c'est le
point d'interrogation par rapport aux
tirs c'est ça s'il est capable d'en
prendre après dribble d'être aussi
efficace que sur les autres situations
eh ben on aura on aura un shooter est qu
un corps d'athlète
là où avant
quand on pensait shooter on pense à
steve kerr oui steve kerr marc marc
promesses là on en est quand même
extrêmement loin mais mine de rien dans
le registre
il peut devenir une sorte de shooter
unidimensionnel très bien alors je
j'enchaîne avec toi nico drafté oui non
à quel niveau à peu près vu son plancher
et plafond jeu draft pour l'instant
dans don classement très secret il est
entre la 20e et la 30e place um
selon l'humeur que j'ai le matin en me
levant mais
lake first round en sachant la marge de
progression sachant ce qu'il est capable
de faire pour moi il est prêt à jouer il
n'est pas prêt à devenir ni 1
imprimé rin et un second de ribaud
länder pour l'instant mais il est prêt à
rendre service à une équipe donc fin de
premier tour - alan
jara depuis c'est à dire du coup c'est
tout ce que je pense entre 20 et 35
désir mais ok hugues exactement la même
chose
je m'enflamme et moi je le monte un peu
plus il va être il peut atteindre mahb
retors loterie fin de ma loterie pour
une équipe un peu plus près ce qu'ils
progressent la connaît justement c'est
quoi le pour finir là-dessus le contexte
idéal de ces une deux premières années à
auch avec bagis sait que c'est une
équipe qui joue déjà des choses précises
c'est quand même une équipe qui est un
peu dans le ventre mou et qu'à un peu de
place dans son roster est ce qu'il va
être capable de compétitionner pour dire
comme benoît lelièvre qu'on salue pour
pour des places dans un roster face à
des joueurs qui sont déjà en nba depuis
deux trois cinq ans si physiquement il
est prêt pour le pur pour le faire pour
moi le contexte idéal c'est un contexte
où il peut jouer parce qu'on l'a 10 50
basket si on veut
continuer à le voir progresser il va
falloir qu'il joue si il est dans une
très grosse équipe ça passera peut-être
par de la g-league mais en tout cas il
va lui falloir du temps de jeu sur le
terrain les entraînements c'est très
bien mais pour pour passer un palier il
faut il faut être santé ne regarde pas
les états les celtics qui veulent du
swing dit moi je trouve ça très bien les
sixers les cases les knicks il ya plein
d'équipés qui vont chercher son profil
d'une équipe où il ya déjà des stars un
peu en termes de bollène ling et lui lit
peuvent provoquer développer progresser
la demande à notre avis à l'envoyer qui
vous gagnez oit g parce que dit il est
pas là c'est pour ça que tu te permets
mais
le contexte je pense par contre que dans
tout type d'équipement a besoin de
joueurs comme ça très honnêtement tout
en tous types d'équipés que faire du
lien et apporter parce que même s'il ya
6 même si va là on tombe dans une équipe
carlin deuxième choix premier tour et
qui veut développer des porteurs de
balle très jeune il aidera à côté parce
qu'il est un peu plus âgé parce que
pourra m'aider parce qu'il peut vivre
sans balle je suis pas que c'est le
meilleur contexte mais je pense que dans
tous les contextes il peut voir 15
minutes en nba l'an prochain je pense
alors peut-être pas voilà brooklyn
ces équipes là mais dans 25 des 30
équipes je pense qu'il peut voir sa
quinzaine de minutes ce serait la
conclusion au tchaï acb agi c'était donc
notre podcast sur le joueur de kansas on
rappelle que sa fiche et sur notre site
envergure point c'est au mercy allan
hughes nico
vous retrouve toutes les semaines sur le
site aussi pour des articles donc voilà
d'ailleurs rien scouting report au
tchèque belgique très complet sur le
site écrit par hugues donc voilà si vous
voulez faire un petit peu de lecture
complémentaire alesi et hugues est ce
que tu as un match en particulier à
conseiller pour
visionner le talent de d'ocha
sur cette année là
on a le match contre saint john qui est
vraiment sympa très bien le match contre
st john's et qui sera saint john's
l'équipe de notre prochain sujet de
podcasts vous laisse le suspense on fait
des bisous ciao tout le monde